Das ist unser Fragenlotto! Es hat böse Fragen und gute oder harmlose Fragen
Du kannst wählen was du willst
- Ich würde es
lieber einfach "blind" machen, hoffentlich was gutes!
Super!
Du musst es drehen, erst die eine und
dann die andere Seite
- Mach du es
Zack
- Ah ok das ist cool, jetzt versteh ich's
Wie bist du, bei all dem Showbusiness, immer noch so natürlch?
Ich trage viel Make-Up, so natürlich bin ich auch nicht
Jetzt reden wir, nicht in die Kamera
- Aber das ist viel unterhaltsamer
Ich weiß nicht, ich sehe das Showbusiness als Karriere und nicht als Lifestyle
Es ist leicht meine Karriere mal an zweiter Stelle zu
haben und ein normales Leben zu Hause zu führen
Ich trage aber viel Make-Up, ich bin nicht so natürlich
wie du denkst, ich sollte das eigentlich garnicht zugeben
-Ja?
Wenn ich zu Hause bin trage ich garkein Make-Up
und mache meine Haare auch nicht so
In dieser Industrie wird man oft aufgestylt, das macht Spaß
Und wie normal ist deine Persönlichkeit, dein Charakter?
Ich finde ich bin sehr natürlich, sehr ehrlich und sehr blond
Ich schrecke alle Jungs weg weil ich so ehrlich bin,
und ihnen immer sage wie die Dinge sind
Ist eigentlich keine gute Sache
Bist du natürlich?
- Ja, ich glaube das ist der Weg zum Erfolg auf YouTube
Du musst natürlich sein, kein Make-Up
- Genau
Fehler machen, schlechtes Englisch reden
- Ja
Und keine Angst vor etwas haben
- Vor nichts Angst haben, das ist richtig!
Das ist wichtig.
- Weiter geht's, hoffentlich noch eine Grüne
Wie viele muss ich beantworten?
- Bis du wenigstens eine rote Frage hattest
Was ist dein Geheimnis für dein Talent als Schauspielerin und Musikerin?
Ich weiß es nicht, ich finde ich bin einfach in der
Industrie aufgewachsen, mein Bruder und mein Vater sind Schauspieler
Bruder und Vater sind Musiker, meine Mutter ist
Lehrerin, ich weiß nicht wie das passt
Aber ich denke ich bin einfach darin aufgewachsen und
habe immer geguckt was die Leute machen
Habe von ihren Fehern gelernt
Du bist mit deinem Talent also seit der Geburt gesegnet?
-
Ja ich kam auf die Welt und konnte singen
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe Musik und Film einfach schon immer geliebt
Ich glaube das hat einfach geholfen
- Das ist also genau das Richtige für dich?
Ja, kreativ zu sein ist mein Ding, ich könnte nicht den ganzen
Tag im Büro sitzen oder nur an einem Ort zu sein
Das ist es wahrscheinlich, ich liebe es zu Reisen,
ich liebe es in verschiedenen Orten zu Arbeiten
Und zu Touren ist wohl das Beste in meinem Leben, weil ich
im Bus mit meinen besten Freunden und der Band bin
Wir reisen alle zusammen
Das ist eines der besten Dinge die ich mache
Das ist der Grund warum dieser Lifestyle zu mir passt
ich kann nicht zu lange an einem Ort bleiben
Das ist also eine "Schwäche" die du hast?
- Ja ich liebe es zu Reisen
Es ist großartig, dass ich meine Freunde mitnehmen kann, ich
war grade auf den Bahamas mit meiner besten Freundin
Habe ihr die Stadt gezeigt als wir in New York waren
Mit meiner Band zu reisen ist auch toll, denn
sie sind auch gute Freunde von mir
Ich liebe jeden der damit zutun hat, den Tour-Manager... alle
Also es ist cool Rockstar zu sein, und nicht wirklich zu arbeiten?
Nein, ich lasse es so klingen als wäre es nicht viel Arbeit
Aber wenn es für dich "Arbeit" ist, hast du keinen
Spaß und bist nicht aus den richtigen Gründen dort
Ich sehe das garnicht als Job an, weil
es sich nicht wie ein Job anfühlt
Schauspielern macht so viel Spaß und es ist wie ein Spiel für mich
Und Musik ist das was ich immer als Hobby hatte, also ich
habe mir schon ausgewählt Musik in der Freizeit zu machen
Das ist nicht wirklich ein Job
Ok, es gibt sowieso nur noch eine Grüne
Hoffentlich ist das nicht zu gemein
Ist es nicht nervig von Miley Cyrus in den Schatten gestellt zu werden?
Ja, sie ist eigentlich ziemlich groß, sie sagt immer sie
ist 1,65m groß aber sie ist so 1,75m groß
Und wenn sie Highheels trägt ist sie riesig
In der Show war es witzig, wenn man 2 Schauspielerinnen in
einer Sendung hat, versucht man sie total anders zu machen
Also ist sie brünett, ich bin blond, sie
ist total groß und ich bin kleiner
Ich weiß nicht mal wie das Wetter "da oben" ist, aber es muss
anders sein, die Leute können einfach von oben auf mich gucken
Aber es gab nie einen Wettstreit, wir haben einfach total verschiedene Lifestyles
Sie ist in Tennessee aufgewachsen und ich in LA, ich weiß
wie es da ist weil ich da schon immer war
Ich denke nicht, dass sie mich überdeckt, weil wir Freunde sind und uns unterstützen
Wenn ich neidisch wäre, dann würde sie mich wohl überdecken, ich finde
das ist eine der blödesten Stimmungen die man haben kann
Neidisch zu sein ist nicht gut
Wenn ich versuchen würde so wie sie zu
sein, dann würde es sich überdeckend anfühlen
Aber weil ich eine eigenständige Person bin, mein eigenes
Leben führe, fühlt es sich nicht überdeckend an
Ich denke wir haben eine lustigere rote Frage
- Eine lustige?
Dein Bruder wurde für einen Oscar nominiert, ist er ein besserer Schauspieler als du?
Natürlich! Ich erinner mich daran wie er zu den
Oscars ging als ich so 8 war
Ich war zu Hause, der Babysitter war da ich hatte eine Pizza vor mir
Ich sagte zu meinem Bruder nur: "Viel Spaß wo auch immer du hingehst!"
Ich habe ein paar schlechte Erinnerungen aus meiner Kindheit, aber das war eine gute
Zum Glück habe ich viele Tagebücher geschrieben
Ich erinner mich wie er aus dem Haus ging und es mir total
egal war, und ich nur daran dachte Ariele, die Meerjungfrau zu gucken
Es ist aber beeindruckend, ich kann es immer noch nicht fassen,
dass er so jung für einen Oscar nominiert wurde
Ein besserer Schauspieler? Ich weiß nicht, ich denke das ist die Entscheidung des Publikums
Er ist auf jeden fall kein besserer Tischtennisspieler als ich
Ich bin ein besserer Tischtennis- und Fußballspieler als er, was noch?
Und ich... bin ein besserer Schwimmer
Ok, eine letzte Frage
- Ok, eine letzte, ich nehme
eine pinke (rote) weil du die so magst
Ja, genau
Hast du ein Privatleben?
Das ist eine der Fragen wo ich lügen sollte
Auf jeden Fall, ich habe noch ein Privatleben
Die meist gestellte Frage, besonders in Deutschland ist: Hast du richtige Freunde?
Und dann sage ich "Ja" und dann fragen sie wer ist
dein Freund und ich sage ihnen: "Den kennt ihr nicht."
Sie fragen dann ob er berühmt ist, und dann
sage ich ihnen, dass er es nicht ist
Ich bin die ganze Zeit bei Leuten die normal sind,
genau wie ich, meine Freunde haben normale Leben
Sie gehen alle aufs College, es ist traurig, alle meine Freunde
sind jetzt auf der Welt verteilt, wegen dem College
Es ist wichtig ein Privatleben zu haben, besonders
in der Industrie in der ich arbeite
Wo die leute sehr gemein zu Mädchen sein können die in dem Geschäft aufwachsen
Es ist wichtig ein Privatleben zu haben was man für sich behält
Und Leute zu haben die genauso sind und nichts privates ausplaudern
Ich war in Brasilien, und die wollten alles wissen wie Sex-Geschichten und so
Es war schrecklich und total peinlich, glaub mir das war eine sehr ängstliche Situation
Aber ich denke man muss mein Privatleben privat halten
Muss man das trennen das Privatleben oder den Beruf oder nicht?
Nein, manchmal kann das Leben in der Öffentlichkeit sehr schwierig sein
Besonders wenn man grade unter Druck steht oder durch eine schwere Zeit geht
Wir wissen alles über die Prominenten, wo sie leben, wo sie
einkaufen, wir kennen die Namen ihrer Kinder, ihre Hunde
Es ist sehr ängstlich, dass all deine persönlichen Dinge ans Licht kommen
Besonders Musiker, weil die ihre Geheimnisse auf der Bühne in Songform erzählen
Aber Schauspieler, ich liebe z.B. Emma Stone, ich weiß nicht welche Haarprodukte sie benutzt
Ich weiß nicht wie ihr Hund heißt, ich weiß nichts über ihr persönliches Leben
Ich weiß nur, dass sie eine tolle Schauspielerin ist
Ich kann mir ihren Film angucken ohne zu denken: "Das ist
doch Emma Watson die das und das Auto fährt"
Ich kann es unterscheiden
Ein Privatleben zu haben ist wichtig... das war keine
harte Frage, das könnte eine Grüne gewesen sein!
Wir dachten es sei eine böse Frage weil wir dir
damit unterstellt haben, dass du kein Privatleben hast
Meinst du?
- Nein
Hast du ein Privatleben, was weiß ich nicht über dich?
Bist du ein Superheld?
- Im Moment, fast nicht
Manchmal ist es schwer, aber ich tue mein Bestes.
- Aber du gibst dein Bestes
Aber es ist eine Frage der Zeit
- Ja da
stimme ich dir voll und ganz zu
Ja wir arbeiten so hart überall, aber man
will auch zu Hause sein Bestes geben
Manchmal ist deine Zeit geteilt und man muss ein paar gute Sachen aufgeben
Man muss manchmal 2 Leute sein
- Was wäre dein Deckname?
Oh gott, Ich weiß es nicht
- Echt? Wenn du
2 Persönlichkeiten hast brauchst du 2 Namen
Ich werde darüber nachdenken, viele Dank
- Ok, cool, Danke!